[Music]
on this Monday night the Prime Minister
hammers home the importance of staying
home we've all seen the pictures online
of people who seem to think they're
invincible well you're not what could
happen next
if Canadians don't listen you're not
just putting yourself at risk you're
putting others at risk too plus games
over breaking news about the Summer
Olympics and the legislation the federal
government plans to introduce the
special powers the Finance Minister
could be given plus New Zealand has no
deaths yet but the whole nation has just
been ordered into self-isolation
global national with Donna freezin
enough is enough go home and stay home
this is what we all need to be doing and
we're going to make sure this happens
whether by educating people more on the
risks or by enforcing the rules if
that's needed it is as close as the
Prime Minister has come to saying he's
ready to take the next step
socializing hanging out on beaches and
in parks is not okay
anyone who does it risk spreading the
virus ignore it and strict limits could
be imposed on your personal freedom good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with new insight into some
extraordinary measures the government is
proposing to tackle the cove in nineteen
pandemic global news has learned the
federal government is poised to table a
bill granting it sweeping new powers to
spend money and raise taxes without
having to get the approval of Parliament
meanwhile some provinces are putting
tougher measures in place already to try
to slow the spread Ontario and Quebec
are shutting down all non-essential
businesses only pharmacies grocery
stores and a few other services will
remain open we'll get to all that in
just a moment but first a status report
on the numbers everyone is watching
positive cases of Kovach 19 and now
surged past 2,000 in Canada BC Alberta
Ontario and Quebec were hardest hit
together they account for more than 90
percent of all confirmed cases though
every province and territory except none
of it now has detected the virus to give
you a sense of how rapidly this pandemic
is accelerating here in the span of
three days the number of confirmed cases
in Canada has more than doubled
Parliament is being recalled to pass
urgent legislation in response to kovat
19 David Aiken has breaking news about
that David Global News has learned the
government is proposing legislation that
will give it extraordinary powers for
quite some time what can you tell us
right well this legislation had been
telegraphed last week Donna as pretty
much pro forma stuff going to formalize
the 27 billion-dollar relief package
announced last week a relief package
that was going to enhance the AI
benefits and enhance Canada child
benefits but there may be some
additional hiccups Global News has been
briefed on some
the contents of the legislation that the
Trudeau minority government will put
before the house tomorrow one section of
the legislation would give Finance
Minister Bill Morneau special powers to
raise taxes lower taxes and changes
isten tax law
all without Parliament's approval either
before the fact or after the fact not
only that Morneau would have this
extraordinary power until December 2021
now we asked the finance ministers
office to comment on this legislation
and what we heard from Bill Morneau's
spokespeople was essentially that
they're not going to comment until the
legislation is actually tabled in the
house John not on Tuesday and they say
they're working with all parties to see
this legislation through but this is a
minority government that is essentially
asking for a blank cheque
to borrow tax and spend for the next 18
months without parliamentary approval I
can tell you that the opposition parties
all of them were surprised when they saw
the text of this legislation today
surprise is a understatement perhaps and
they're all very anxious about giving
Morneau these new powers and so what do
they do they are going to strategize
overnight about this they do have more
combined votes than the government do
they amend the legislation do they
defeat it that's what they'll have to
discover Madonna just to sum up how
historic this is even in the first world
war in the Second World War
no Finance Minister asked or got these
kind of powers because of course
Parliament was able to sit all through
those crises those national emergencies
and vote on legislation and I'm sure the
Liberals tomorrow will be saying they
need some of these big peak hours
because for the first time in our
history we may have to limit
Parliament's ability to meet because of
this public health crisis Donna
absolutely extraordinary times and so
much on the line David thank you let's
go to our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson Mercedes can you give us some
context here on what this legislation
might mean well Donna it basically means
that the Finance Minister can tax and
spend if this goes ahead until December
of 2021 without having to seek the
authority of Parliament and basically
the most important function that
Parliament has is to approve things like
taxation and spending
of government money historically through
Westminster democracy that has really
been a focal point the idea that you
don't have taxation without
representation it's particularly
remarkable in this case because it's a
minority government that is asking for
these powers that as David said are
absolutely unprecedented even during
times of World Wars you didn't have
finance ministers who had the ability to
circumvent Parliament to make decisions
about government spending raising or
lowering taxes without having to seek
the consent of elected officials the
fact that goes until December of 2021 is
also remarkable and right now the
opposition is trying to figure out what
to do with this they weren't expecting
it and they're frustrated trying to
decide how to work with the government
because they do want to make sure that
people are able to get the resources
they need the same goals that the
government has said that they have but
they feel that this ask goes too far in
many cases and that sets potentially a
dangerous precedent so it'll be very
interesting to hear how the government
defends why they're asking for something
so extraordinary and it's also raising
questions for some MPs Donna
but whether Parliament can do some of
its work in another way either with
minimum staffing from social distancing
or from home they're saying that every
other industry is learning to adapt to
the new normal perhaps Parliament should
too instead of simply suspending sitting
and making democratic decisions well
right Mercedes Stevenson thus thanks the
prime minister's message to Canadians
today's behave as if you have the virus
and don't do anything that risks
spreading it Michel Couture on Prime
Minister Trudeau's tough talk and what
it means for you listening is your duty
and staying home is your way to serve
practically pleading with people Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau's message to
Canadians your cooperation is key to
limiting the spread of kovat 19 and
despite weeks of repeating that the
government clearly didn't get through to
hundreds of people in BC this past
weekend when we see images of people out
enjoying the sunshine in large groups
that is extremely concerning because
they are not just putting themselves at
risk they are putting everyone else at
risk
a Trudeau still says nothing is off the
table when it comes to forcing people to
stay inside including the Emergencies
Act and the Deputy Prime Minister says
they will consult Premier's about it
during a conference call Monday evening
getting a clearer sense of both what the
situation is across the country and
where the Premier's feel they do or do
not have the necessary tools in their
own provincial and territorial toolboxes
Monday the premiers of Quebec and
Ontario brought down the hammer cost
while ago closing all non-essential
businesses at midnight Tuesday as his
province saw a massive jump in the
number of kovat 19 cases we must put
Quebec on pause until Easter for a
possible restart on April 13 the premier
Ford is doing the same but only for two
weeks and like in Quebec both grocery
stores and pharmacies will remain open
Ford feels the time to act is now our
resources are spread thin we want to
focus on making sure we flatten this
curve and contain the spread aiming to
do the same the federal government has
earmarked 192 million of the billion
dollar kovat 19 Response Fund for
research and development of a Canadian
vaccine for the virus a Trudeau points
out it will take months to develop a
vaccine so while that work is ongoing he
wants Canadians to do their part by
staying apart Donna
Michael Couture in Ottawa thanks well
there are thousands of people across
this country right now bracing for
what's coming there the medical staff
who are already treating those who are
ill with Kovan 19 and those who are
waiting they all look to Italy and Spain
and elsewhere wondering what if that
happens here will we be able to save
lives and have enough personal
protection equipment to save ourselves
Abigail Beeman is looking into that
tonight Global News obtained an email to
staff at Lakeridge Health announcing the
Ontario Hospital is canceling all
surgeries with the exception of life and
limb saying the main reason to
Kancil is shortage of personal
protective equipment we want everyone to
know that we have adequate supplies the
head of the Canadian Medical Association
says otherwise hearing from doctors
nationwide they are worried that there
is insufficient number of ventilators
and an inadequate supply of personal
protective equipment across the country
five days ago
pharmacists pleaded to be recognized as
essential health care providers in terms
of supply pharmacies across the country
you're now putting up plexiglass or on
their dispensaries and plastic
screenings but there is a definite you
know lack of supply of being able to get
things like masks gloves other things
like that the federal Health Minister
was more specific I could say that we
have enough PPEs for the next week or
two Patti hi do urging hospitals facing
shortages to talk to their provincial
ministry we're working very closely with
all of the provincial territorial
ministers of health to make sure that we
understand what we have and how we can
allocate it to need very specific needs
and very specific regions former health
minister dr. Jane Philpott has joined
the frontlines working at a Colvin 19
assessment centre trailer at Markham
Stouffville hospital we actually have a
special tent outside with a nurse who's
wearing full protective equipment that's
doing this well while companies rushed
to help integrates the functions of a
ventilator generating its own oxygen
from the air
Toronto's Thornhill Medical with a
self-contained ventilator Ottawa
Spartans bioscience with a quick test
you put that into our device then you
hit go and then in 30 minutes that gives
you your results
both among the companies promised
federal funding both waiting for further
instruction before they can wrap up
supply apical Beeman global news Ottawa
the u.s. is quickly becoming a hot zone
there are more than 43,000 cases now and
New York City is a hot zone itself there
are more than 20,000 confirmed cases in
New York State their outbreaks - in
states like Louisiana where millions
recently celebrated Mardi Gras as
Jackson prosecco reports it's deeply
worrying and adding urgency to calls for
a federal bailout New York is now the
epicenter of the epidemic in the u.s.
with more than 10,000 confirmed cases of
kovat 19 in New York City alone I want
America to understand this week it's
going to get bad hospitals have been
told to increase their capacity by at
least 50%
a convention center in Manhattan is
being converted into a 1,000 bed field
hospital for the difficult days ahead
that trajectory is going up the wave is
still going up and we have a lot of work
to do to get that rate down state
governors are pleading with the White
House to nationalize production of
essential medical supplies like masks
and ventilators we just received our
allotment from the federal government's
national strategic stockpile is it
barely enough to cover one shift at that
hospital not even a full day's worth 100
million Americans nearly one in every
three face direct orders from their
local governments to stay home Louisiana
where more than a million tourists
celebrated Mardi Gras last month is
reporting the fastest growth of
confirmed cases in the world according
to local doctors this is disgraceful we
do not have time but as the US economy
nosedives help is caught up in political
wrangling in Washington lawmakers remain
deadlocked over a two trillion dollar
aid package concerned unrestricted
handouts to corporations won't offer
long-term relief to the workers who need
them why do the members of the United
States Senate continue to Double Down
on stupid more than 100 people have died
from kovat 19 in the US today alone yet
President Trump seems intent on lifting
restrictions and getting people back to
work as soon as possible perhaps within
one week this morning he tweeted that
the cure should not be worse than the
problem but his ambition flies in the
face of the reality medical experts say
the u.s. he's now facing Donna a grim
reality Jackson prosecco in Washington
thanks there is more bad news for the
airline industry tonight montreal-based
Air Transat is temporarily laying off
70% of its workforce all flight crew
personnel will be out of a job about
3,600 people some of the layoffs are
effective immediately others will be
more gradual so the company can help
repatriate Canadians the last scheduled
flight is April 1st Air Canada which is
also temporarily laid off more than
5,000 workers will repatriate stranded
Canadians from Peru Spain and Ecuador
this week new orders in New Zealand and
the United Kingdom coming up two
countries taking unprecedented measures
the Olympic Games are in serious doubt a
longtime member of the International
Olympic Committee believes the Summer
Games will be postponed because of the
Cova 19 pandemic and Canada has already
stated that Team Canada will not
participate Erik Sorenson reports on the
push to postpone Tokyo the moment Tokyo
won the Summer Olympics then seven years
of preparation it's hard to let go for
Japan and the International Olympic
Committee
but former IOC vice president Canadian
dick pound says the decision has been
made more than four months to go Thomas
Bach and the IOC are still giving
themselves four weeks before formally
deciding but postponement became
virtually inevitable after the Canadian
Olympic and Paralympic committees were
the first to say their athletes won't be
going issuing this statement while we
recognize the inherent complexities
around postponement nothing is more
important than the health and safety of
our athletes and the world community
Olympic trampoline gold medalist Rosie
McLennan it's not the time where we
should be trying to reach our peak
performance or thinking about that it's
the time where we need to be focusing on
protecting the vulnerable population
gold medal wrestler Erica wieb says it
is the right decision I'm heartbroken
and I hope that this will no allow this
IOC to take the right steps and postpone
the games for a year and this Paralympic
triathlete agrees having this decision
we can actually truly take a pause from
training and truly isolate and truly do
what's best for the community it is
heartache for the Japanese to with
Canada out followed quickly by Australia
the games for this summer were clearly
unravelling
in a room with faces covered in masks
the head of Japan's Olympic Committee
was resigned a new student then he
suggests the postponing period shouldn't
be long it will still take weeks for the
IOC to rework agreements for broadcast
hotels facilities and the overlap with
other world sporting events next year
the complexity of this is close to
impossible to understand but it had to
happen the Prime Minister thanking
Canadian athletes for helping to make it
happen but this was absolutely the right
call and everyone should follow their
lead
and it looks like the world will be
following the Canadian lead Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
still ahead New Zealand's Prime Minister
acts fast and hard to avoid a worst case
scenario
New Zealand's Prime Minister is taking
radical steps to contain kovat 19 their
Jacinda are durn said today we only have
a hundred and two cases but so did Italy
once she is now imposing a month-long
nationwide lockdown every household will
go into scythe self-isolation from
Wednesday night for at least four weeks
apart from people who work in essential
services these decisions will place the
most significant restrictions on New
Zealanders movements in modern history
over the next 48 hours people will need
to go home be it locally or throughout
the country and Prime Minister Boris
Johnson put the UK on lockdown today he
gave the police a special power to
arrest and find people still ignoring
the advice to keep some physical
distance from each other in London parks
have been packed people have crammed
into the underground
even though cases there have surged
almost 7000 and 55 people died today
alone here's crystal commencing this was
the scene on the tube Monday morning no
surprise the government introduced new
measures restricting when people can
leave their homes essentially only to
buy groceries go for a walk a day and
for medical visits if you don't follow
the rules
the police will have the powers to
enforce them including through fines and
dispersing gatherings the changes come
as a group of health care workers
confessed their fears we are facing our
greatest challenge and we're frightened
we all have a choice if you choose to
stay at home you will see of lives
keeping those on the front lines safe is
crucial efforts are underway to pack and
ship more than 1 million masks and other
protective items to health care workers
in the UK it follows the government's
admission that there are not enough
supplies for health care workers the
delivery has been tasked to the military
in eastern France military members also
called to action this is one of many
field hospitals being set up
around Europe with so many cases in
Spain a hotel in Barcelona has been
designated a care location for patients
with less severe symptoms never before
in peace times have such steps been
taken in addition to border closures
curfews and lock downs more than 300,000
cases of kovat 19 have now been reported
to whu-oh that's heartbreaking
heartbreaking is the right word
overnight Sunday to Monday there were
more than 460 deaths in Italy the new
restrictions in the UK are aimed at
preventing scenes like this crystal de
Manson Global News London
next songs for self isolation
[Music]
Canadian Bruce Aylward is one of the top
doctors tracking this pandemic he's
senior advisor to the director-general
of the World Health Organization I spoke
to him today from Geneva you can hear
the full interview tonight on our
network special but here's a preview
about what he says about isolating
testing early breaking the chain of
transmission and what happens if you
wait too long this is a virus that once
it does take off it's going to move and
increase exponentially and your measures
your control measures have got to be
exponential as well to get in front of
it so small incremental measures won't
work and if there's a sense that you're
losing control of these clusters losing
control of these transmission chains you
want to be moving very very quickly in
terms of measures that are going to
really prevent people from interacting
in a way that that's going to just add
more fuel to this particular fire you
can hear much more later tonight in our
global news special coronavirus Canada
in crisis and that is global national
for this Monday I'm Donna Friesen we
leave you tonight with Toronto's soprano
taya
Kasahara she's singing from a balcony
lifting spirits and soothing Souls take
care of yourself
[Music]
[Music]